mr du drôle avec du triste c'est le prêt
de guy bedos une véritable devise
d'alchimiste mais ça tombe bien
guy bedos en étant voilà quarante ans
qu'il transmute le poussier de notre
époque en rire 18 carats avec lui ça
grince ça chahute ça dérange s'est
engagé dégagé emballé mais ça pèse
toujours bon poids comme dans le dvd de
son dernier spectacle
guy bedos en piste en édition simple ou
mieux en version collector 2 dvd
guy bedos est en tournée en vrai dans
toute la france avec ce spectacle
jusqu'au 16 avril
dans son journal intime il nous confie
qu'il rêve de rencontrer michel onfray
le philosophe et l'humoriste seul en
piste ce sera une belle affiche non en
tout cas moi ça me plairait j'aime guy
bedos allez me dire et alors alors rien
je voulais lui dire c'est tout
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis très très
très vigilant sur le respect qui est dû
à chaque être humain quel qu'il soit je
suis allé dans un bel hôtel de la baule
par exemple et que la femme de chambre à
qui il demandait des nouvelles de de sa
famille de sa santé sa liste
extraordinaire il ya plein d'artistes
qui viennent là vous êtes le premier qui
me parlent tout ça d extravagant puisque
quand même j'avais la chance d'avoir une
très belle chambre elle venait faire le
ménage je peux peut-être lui parler non
quand même c'était un être humain je me
voyais déjà
haut de l'affiché
en dix fois plus gros que n'importe qui
m'ont nuances et à l'est
je me voyais déjà adulé mon père mes
parents
d'ailleurs c'est moi genre self made man
je me suis fait tout seul mon plein des
absents complètement dans ma vie je n'ai
vu un peu comme ça je les croisais bras
série serrée dans ses bras
j'avais plus de nouvelles de lui pendant
cinq ans mes parents étaient séparés le
pied c'est que je me suis habitué à son
absence quand j'étais petit je pleurais
il me manquait je me suis construit
vraiment contre contre voilà je suis
construit contre contre ce que j'ai vu
ce que j'ai entendu ce que j'ai subi
aussi des coûts la violence verbale
physique là ce juge qui m'est resté
c'est une certaine violence verbale
c'est vrai merci d'être là
je fais mon numéro de vieilles [ __ ] et
vous marchez tué kennedy ils ont perdu
la main ou quoi
sakho 6 j'ai remplacé les coup par
démont
[Musique]
cette exclusion retomber en enfance par
exemple ça peut être très émouvant
cette femme qui a été vraiment dur m'a
frappé quand j'étais gosse elle a l'air
d'une petite fille mme et une fois en
vouloir une petite fille elle me regarde
comme si j'étais l'archange gabriel
elle me dit qu'elle m'a toujours adoré
carrément juillet basse et les 70
premières années qui ont été les plus
longues
quelle pudeur mon dieu quelle pudeur et
et elle me fait de la peine parce que je
l'aimais moi quand j'étais petit et je
laime de nouveau
[Musique]
la police française en ce moment se
comporte avec guerre avec les étrangers
en général se comporte
un peu comme la police française pendant
l'occupation oui je suis désolé oui oui
oui je le pense
le mari de ma mère qui me détester et je
le lui rendait bien était d'extrême
droite et ma mère s'est baladé dans les
airs la photo du maréchal pétain dans
son sac
après que mitterrand a été élu jeudi
elle a fait la soudure
[Musique]
mitterrand à vichy pétain a pas tout
c'était presque une visionnaire j'ai
détesté la bourgeoisie telles que je les
ai vécus en deux cas il ya les bons
rails tout à fait fréquentable
moi même je suis pas sûr de pas vivre
combat beaucoup comme on dit maintenant
mais la façon dont on traiter
les gens qui travaillaient notamment les
algériens et les algériennes et cetera
la sonnette sous la table où la
clochette sur sur la table j'ai eu
horreur même enfant de tout ça quand
j'étais en cinquième au lycée nous
sommes toujours amis ce garçon mémoire
il y avait eu nigériens dans la classe
un seul est rien c'est ça justifie
d'ailleurs d'algérie si tant est qu'on
puisse justifier une guerre
heureux qui comme ulysse a fait un beau
voyage
heureux qui comme ulysse à vue sans
paysage j'ai admiré beaucoup moi
beaucoup de gens dans le spectacle j'ai
eu des parrains marraines formidable
barbara brel ou des amis comme nougaro
brassens si plus permis les créateurs
artistes ou les intellectuels
plus se porte mais admiration j'ai eu
l'occasion de parler au téléphone je ne
savais pas qu'il était malade avec bon
dieu mais bourdieu il m'a parlé il m'a
mis à l'aise et des provinces de france
moi j'étais à cluj j'ai remarqué que
ceux sur les gens n'est plus les plus
conséquents qui sont souvent les plus
modestes et plus simple et plus direct
il la ramène pas sûr qu'on ait un type
que je veux absolument rencontrer c'est
michel onfray parce que ça fait un
moment que je le pourchasser je crois
que nous sommes deux hétérosexuels ou
militants l'un et l'autre mais mais je
suis extrêmement c'est lui parce qu'il
écrit parce qu'ils y aussi parce que
j'ai des vues à la télévision je vais
écouter la radio
c'est un discours qui me va très bien on
parlait du talent oratoire de mon point
de vue mitterrand est un des derniers à
avoir eu ça ça m'a fait beaucoup de
peine je me suis payé une crise de
l'adolescence à 60 verges
quand j'ai su que mitterrand avait pour
ami jusqu'en 86 rené bousquet en lisant
le livre de pierre péan il faisait une
enquête sur sur les années vichy ménibus
de mitterrand brrr comme dans un hôtel
photographe remonter tout le temps et
voilà alors il n'y en a parlé puis
mitterrand on n'a pas vu une énorme
chose que c'était didac il a accepté de
collaborer d'une si j'ose dire si murray
avait inventé un jeu un peu
approximative un peu aléatoire le jeu du
que la boe du résistant et on faisait
des listes parmi des gens des médias du
cinéma du théâtre et déjà à l'époque la
liste des collabos était beaucoup plus
importante mais à mon avis elle
s'allonge d'année
en année oui oui y'a pas beaucoup de
jean moulin
parmi nos camarades
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]